foreign
[Music]
well when we perform our landship which
is one of our traditional dancers in our
map called we also celebrating a lot of
the Traditions that even were brought
here by the persons who had enslaved us
but we would have transformed them into
movements that we would have made for
our celebration and also to appreciate
despite the challenges that we can set
our people have a sense of resilience
and they could take a lot and transform
it into something beautiful
[Music]
this is
that's part of the reason why we've hung
this Gallery this way it's a kind of
retelling of traditional narratives
narratives that until really recently
only in the last 20 or 30 years have had
to be
Rewritten
reconceptualized or Rewritten
particularly when we were talking about
education for young people but until
young people see themselves in terms of
individuals taking charge of a narrative
they don't get that they have a right to
identify themselves in a particular way
thank you
foreign